so as you know there is a slight drought
in terms of that no golf balls have been
made this year so it's true people are
having to use smaller fruits you're
going from a red apple today
yeah slightly unreliable but yeah
generally good choice and 9-iron for
know it's a bit of a pitching wedge bit
longish get bit off from that yeah
hundred yards maybe yeah all right go
for it
yeah mr. completely
you know
well you're some good distance on that
yes I think you're on the fairway so
let's see if I might reach the green
good for birdie
yeah
I'll be already on this yeah yeah ready
yeah
no gonna practice if you upstart what
good what's all my stunts ready yeah I
did it in the face yeah
you
well it turns out that golf ball drought
I mentioned earlier um was actually a
lie I was just full-on
lying about that so there's a golf ball
there's a high-speed camera five
thousand frames let's see what it looks
like oh good I'll do it
this is the most annoying spot I never
wanna play golf
ever ever